[MUSIC]
Many students, myself included,
are worried about their test scores,
what advice do you have there?
This is probably the most frequently asked
question that I get is what about my GMAT
score, what about my GRE?
Well, we accept students with
a wide range of test scores and
it is just one data point,
and I truly mean that.
So, my best advice is,
well, we look at the tests.
And they are important to ensure that
you're going to be able to thrive
quantitatively and
verbally in the program.
So my best advice is, we look at it,
you should spend some time preparing.
What I hope for every applicant is,
when they submit that score, and
I know it's stressful.
That you feel it's at least a decent
reflection of what your capabilities are,
so that's where the preparation comes in.
That being said though, I know for many
students, test taking is not their forte.
So, again, if there's a score honestly on
an application where it's far from maybe
what our median might be.
And we do admit people in the 500s,
the 600s and the 700s, but
if I see this may not be the strongest
point of their application.
That's when I'm diving into the transcript
and seeing, again, how do they learn?
Maybe tests just aren't their thing.